ll rose to fame with songs like going
back to cali and mama said knock you out
the two-time grammy winner is the first
rapper to rack up ten
check that ten ten consecutive platinum
selling albums he was recently inducted
to the rock and roll hall of fame
rightfully so took long enough and now
he's hosting a hip-hop festival in his
hometown of queens new york saturday's
rock the bells festival will feature
some of the biggest names in hip-hop
like little kim busta rhymes ice cube
and more llc is joining us right now
what's up baby how you doing man i'm
feeling great happy to be here um just
really excited about you know what we're
doing for hip-hop culture um you know
this is like the first time that you
know timeless and classic hip-hop is
being served to the world on a on a
silver platter yeah so to speak so it's
a completely immersive experience it's
like an opportunity for people that you
know love the music you love the
musicality of it who love the creativity
love the artistry to just enjoy
themselves as food activations it's
gonna be crazy one day festival since
since you came into the game you've
always wore the code of hip-hop proudly
why is it important to put together a
festival like this because i felt like
hip-hop culture is not disposable
and um hip-hop culture is more than
whatever is happening on the current
billboard charts it's not just that it
includes that but it's not only that and
i feel like you know
you know this culture deserves to be
celebrated and elevated when i think
about guys like
paul mccartney who i respect and love
and know um or mick jagger or uh
bob dylan right the way they're
celebrated and appreciated i think that
these hip-hop artists deserve that same
appreciation that's a fact but the kinds
of contribution that they've made um to
american culture and so you know rock
the bells is my opportunity and my way
of just paying it forward and saying yo
this culture is important yeah this
culture has touched a lot of lives in a
lot of ways let's lift it up and
celebrate it you've done something that
very few artists have have been able to
do and you sort of like showed the
flight path but you never ever forgot
home you never forgotten your roots
kind of take us through how you were
able to be so successful not only in you
know music but television movies beyond
i mean what was the one thing that got
you through well you know i was raised
with faith in god i mean let's start
there um also um you know just having a
work ethic you know my grandmother
always told me if a task is once begun
never leave it till it's done be thy
label great or small do it well or not
at all and i grew up with a man
and so you know when you have faith and
you have a work ethic and then you get
out there and you put the energy in and
you you're confident about what you're
doing but you don't get arrogant and
start running around with the long
cigarette holder and the ascot you know
you're confident but but you still have
the confidence to be humble and approach
the work with humility and approach the
world with humility you could do great
things and so you know something like
this for me is like a dream come true i
was born i'm like i call i'm generation
one fan of hip-hop and generation 1.5 is
an artist right you know there was a
treacherous in there of course crash
crew and there was a you know the
furious five and all of those guys that
came before me as women but you know
pebbly pool and all of them she was
right there in the beginning
no question i was right there i was in
the crowd but i was there
so you're a boss now but let's go back
to that new york city neighborhood and
that young kid right wanting to prove
himself wanting to get to where he is
today what did you think then
of hip-hop music and culture
it was the first time that i heard black
men um and women sound empowered you
know when you grow up in a neighborhood
like like i grew up in saint armas
hollis jamaica queens when you grow up
in those kinds of areas
um you feel invisible
you feel like nobody cares your friend
gets shot or dies on up the block he
gets killed and there's a reef on the
corner and some candles and then life
goes on nobody talks about it nobody
seems to ever care other than within the
community and so hip-hop was the first
time that was the first time i heard
you know black men being empowered and
saying something that really meant
something to me you know just the fact
that they were sounding powerful this
was before the messages got really
really deep this was before like even
the message that melly mel wrote which
was one of the most transformative
hip-hop records ever but
before that it was just the idea that
they sounded confident and they sounded
powerful it's no different from seeing
an athlete who you know just does a
certain thing and it makes you feel like
hey i could do that right if he could do
that i could do that and that's how i
felt about it so you know growing up in
the hood that's what you think right so
the the goal is not to pretend like i'm
not from the hood and the goal is not to
over emphasize it the goal is to just be
true to who you are and lift up this
culture and this platform and that's
what we're doing with rock the bells you
know what it's like to be without um
those young people that are watching
right now that are struggling struggling
with their identity struggling
financially yeah struggling in their
house
without a representation of a male or
woman father figure or a mom in the
house
what is your advice to them as as they
look in the mirror and they don't feel
like they're worthy well i tell you man
you know
i remember
you know leaving home early
and you know searching through fat back
looking for little pieces of meat
just to eat i remember you know leaving
the refrigerator open because it was so
amazing that we had food in it and
that's not because my mother didn't work
hard right but she didn't put a lot of
energy into raising me really well right
delivered right i'm just saying
sometimes it was tough so the thing is
to not get frustrated
to to to to continue to believe in
yourself right
um and believe in the power of your
dream and to know that no matter
how
you know
just
marginalized you may feel you're not
insignificant and one person can make a
huge huge difference in the world like
one person and you can be that person
you are inspirational as we just heard
but there are some people who are going
to be watching this who say i didn't
know ll from his music i actually saw
him on television right another one good
finish this question for me my life's
intention is
to inspire people
with um by lifting up hip-hop culture
and taking hip-hop culture everywhere i
go and introducing it to the world and
if if that's through if they know me
through acting great guess what you know
me through acting now come check out
this festival and see what i do
you know what i'm saying yes and if you
know me from hosting cool listen
come check this out see what i do for
real see why i got to do because i
wouldn't be doing ncis la i wouldn't be
doing hosting the grammys i wouldn't be
doing all of these other things that
without before bingo without this that's
right yeah you know what i mean this is
where it started but speaking of music
what's up with the album man let me get
right to it
[Laughter]
baby
yeah she just delivered good too she
said i'm bad on the album i like that
i like that she said i wonder where she
got that from i don't know i'm not
saying she got it from me but i didn't
like she said it and her mom is a close
friend she's very nice so um
you know what we just finished the
record i just finished the new album
q-tip executive produced it he did a
tremendous job on the record um uh i'm
not ready yet to tell people to guess
but uh i got some some cool features on
it okay it's gonna be a lot of fun when
it comes out and you're gonna come back
on this show coming back
don't call it and come back
[Laughter]
hey at the end of the day thank you for
being authentic that's real
thank you yeah i i saw the glasses come
off i'm waiting for the hat to come off
yeah it'll come off eventually but you
got the ball uh
[Laughter]
the rock the bells festival is this
saturday
it is this saturday no question august
6. there it is